[تصفيق]
يا ترى انت عم تشتغل شي بتحبه
السؤال موجه لالك سؤال موجه لالك السؤال
موجه لالكم يمكن اغلب الاجابات راح تكون
ما بعرف
لان غالبا انت ما سالت حالك هذا السؤال من
قبل
افعل ما تحب من اكثر الاقتباسات المشهوره
اغلبيتها ولكن للاسف نحن فقط بنعرفه بجوز
سمعت هالجمله بمكان مع السوشيال ميديا او
حدا خبرك اياها او قراتها بشي كتاب ومارقت
في وقتها على ذهنك مرور الكرام لكن مجرد
ما تفكر بالاقتباس بتحس بالسعاده لان
لطالما ربط شعور السعاده بالحب وباليوم
الاول يلي بتطبق فيه هاد الاقتباس بتكون
بدات مشوار نجاحك اسمي ماجد زبيده مسؤول
تسويق بشركه المشهوره للاستشارات والتدريب
يمكن
كلياتكم سمعتوها للعباره وخلاص هلا صار
عندكم فكره التوك رح يكون عن افعل ما تحب
اليوم ماني جايه احكي خطاب تحفيزي ولا
جايه احكي قصه نجاح حدثت بظروف مثاليه انا
جاي احكي حقائق كيف تفعل ما تحب
كلياتنا بنعرف
او ما بنعرف بالاحرى ليش لازم اشتغل شي
بحبه ويمكن في اشخاص عندهم فكره في اشخاص
ما عندهم فكره الانسان اللي بيشتغل شي
بحبه بكون مبدع بكون متميز بتلاقيه دائما
بيشتغل من قلبه وبيقدم كامل ما عنده لا
بكل ولا بيمل بشتغل اوفر تايم هو مبسوط
بفيق كل يوم على شهدو هو مبسوط
هو مبسوط وبيستنى الباص لحتى يروح على
شغله وهو مبسوط الدراسات بتقول انه 80% من
الاشخاص الناجحين هن اللي بيشتغلوا شيء
بحبوه
وبالاضافه لذلك انه اللي بيشتغل شيء بحبه
ما بيستسلم بكون دائما في عنده فكره
مستحيل انه يتخلى عنك قادر انه يبذروا
الغالي والرخيص تجاهها لكن مستحيل يتركها
اربعه ايام
بحث
تعمق تجربه هكذا تصنع كل القناعات تجاه
الشيء اللي انت مفكر انك بتحبه وبدك
تشتغله ابحث وكبر معرفتك فيه وبعدين بعد
ما تحس انه خلصت مرحله البحث اتعمق بالبحث
روح شوف اشخاص عم يشتغلون زيت على ارض
الواقع شوف المردود المادي شوف مستقبله
بعدين انتقل لمرحله التجريب هلا بمرحله
التجريب رح تواجه طريقين الاول هو انه رح
تلاقي شيء يلي قراته بحثت عنه مطابق تماما
لما يتم على ارض الواقع انت هون بتكون
خلصت مرحله صناعه القناعه وبتبلش او رح
تلاقي انه الحكي مو ناقص تماما لما قراته
وبحثت عنه هلا هون ما بتحس انه انت خلص
وما عاد غدرت يكمل لا لا الامور كتير
بسيطه
تنسحب بترجع بتبحث بتتعمق وبتجرب هلا
بتقول لي انا بحثت واتعمقت وجربت هيك انا
بكون خلصت تمام لا لا ابدا ابدا انت هلا
بتكون متل يعني لبس لباس معركه لكن ما معه
سلاح طب شو سلاحي سلاحك هو تنميه المهاره
برحله البحث عن تنميه المهاره انت راح
تكون بالضبط عرفان شو بدك وعلى شو عم تدور
ما راح تكون انسان ضايعه عم يدور على كورس
تدريبي لحتى يحضروا وبعدها يروح يبلش شغل
لا لا انت راح تكون عرفان ادق التفاصيل عن
اي برنامج انت راح تروح تحضره راح تكون
حتى بالبرنامج متميز راح تكون غير كل
الاشخاص اشخاص هدول ممكن يكونوا جايين بس
انه بدي احضر برنامج لحتى ازيد معرفتي انت
راح تكون جاي لتنطلق بعدها لسوق العمل
طب انا خلصت رحله البحث هلا شو بسوي هلا
بصير انه انت انسان قادر تفوت على سوق
العمل لتشتغل شيء بتحبه طبعا على ارض
الواقع اي نعم بمثال ليس ببعيد الشخص اللي
واقف قدامكم
كلياتنا منعرف انه في شخص او اي شخص يواجه
نقله نوعيه بحياته بتغير له وجهه نظره
وتفكيره وانا واجهتها النقل تماما بعد ما
انقبلت بجامعه اختصاص اداره اعمال
انقبلت صرت دوا بالاختصاصات اللي بقلب
الجامعه شو ممكن اختص انا بعد ما اخلص
قرات عن الاول مقاله ما كملت اربع اسطر
مليت تاني ثالث الرابع كان ماركتينج قرات
المقالب الاولى والثانيه والثالثه
والرابعه والخامسه حسيت حالي ما اكتفيت
رحت صرت تدور اكتر ودور ودور ودور رحت مع
حسيت انه خلص انا هذا المجال راح اشتغل
فيه وهذا المجال اللي راح ادرسه
حالي معقول استنى الجامعه لحتى تعلمني
التسويق انتقلت لمرحله البحث عن تنميه
المهاره صرت تدور على كورسات على الاون
لاين وكورسات على ارض الواقع كتب كتيبات
مقالات اشخاص ناجحين بالمجال وتابعهم وما
بنكر انه في شغلات فادتني وشغلات لا
طيب وانت وصلت
ماجد لما كان عمره 19 سنه اسس متجر
الكتروني
مع اني تعاقدت مع تجار وصورت منتجاتهم
وسوقت لمنتجاتهم وعرضتهم بقلب التطبيق بس
بغض النظر عن كل الاسباب هو فشل هل يمكن
انتم تشوفوها انه هي فشل بس انا كنت
شايفها خطوه عظيمه لحتى انتقل لنجاح اكبر
واعظم طيب وشو عملت ماجد هلا هو بالمراحل
الاخيره لاطلاق مشروع الثاني بالاضافه اني
صرت مسؤول تسويق بشركه المشوره وشركه
المشوره مو اي شركه اللي ما بيعرفها هي
الشركه الاولى المرخصه بسوريا لتقديم
الخدمات الاستشاريه والتدريب للمؤسسات
الماليه والشركات يعني صناعه القناعه
وتنميه المهاره فعاله المطلوب منا انه بس
تبحث
واي شخص بدور على شيء بلاقي راح ارجع
اعيدها هي شخص بدور على شيء
تاكيد على هذا الحكي بيقولوا في ملك قرر
يعمر قصر ببلده جديده جابت قضاه وبعدهم عن
هالبدة بدون ما يعرف ولا واحد وجود الثاني
غابوا شهد ورجعوا شعب القاضي أول قال له
احكيلنا شو شفت بهالبده انا جلاله الملك
بلالك اياها البلده كل سكان حراميه
ونصابين وفيها فواحش والخمر بالطرقات
ندور على بدله تانيه ونعمل قصر
انا هلا بدي منك تطلب امر دغري نبلش نعمر
قصر قال له البلده معبايه علم وتعليم
ومراكز تعليميه وجامعات سكانها 90% من
المثقفين
جاب الشخص التالت القاضي قال له شو شفت
جلاله الملك هي اعظم بلده في التاريخ كل
حياتي قال له ليش قالو فيها الدين منتشر
بشكل رهيب لما وصلت على البلده كان المؤذن
عم يقول الله اكبر العالم سكرت محلاتها
وفادت على الجوامع فيها مراكز لتحفيز
القران وسكانها كلهم بيخافوا الله قال
الوجهات الملك انا بنصحك هلا هلا تنتقل
لمرحله انه نحن نبني القصر وتاكيدا على
هاد واكثر من هيك انه اللي بدور على شيء
بلاقيه قوله سبحانه وتعالى وانا ليس
للانسان الا ما سعى
ما في حظ حرفيا هي القصه الشغله هاي
الشغله الوحيده اللي ما فيها حظ المطلوب
منك بس تبحث تصنع قناعه تجاه شغل بعدين
تنتقل لمرحله تنميه المهاره وتفوت لسوق
العمل هلا بدك تسالني ليش انت عم تشتغل
المسؤول تسويق وعم تعمل مشروع خاص فيه
لانه لما فشل مشروع الاول اجى شخص لعندي
وحكى لي كلمه كانت اعظم عباره سمعتها بكل
حياتي اللي انت بهذا العمر لازم تشتغل
شغلين الشغله الاول بسد لك احتياجاتك
الماديه والشغله الثانيه قادر انه يحقق لك
احلامك هلا انا بدي اعطي نصيحه لكل الشباب
اللي عم يسمعوني اللي هنا من عمري نحن
لساتنا بمقتبل العمر لساتها باول طريقنا
ومسارنا المهني نقدر نصنع قناعات وننمي
مهارات لسه ما خلطنا بسوق العمل وقادرين
انه نخلق فاعليه وكفاءه كبيره بالكوادر
اللي راح تنطلق وتفوت على سوق العمل ولا
تظل تقول انا لازم اكون بمكان تاني انا
لازم اكون بمكان تاني لانه باكد لك المكان
الثاني اللي عم تقول انت بدك تروح له بس
توصل رح تقول نفس الجمله انا لازم اكون
بمكان تاني انا لازم اكون بمكان تاني
الشغله موصول الشغله بالرحله
الافعى بتوصل للقمه تبع الجبل والصقر
بيوصل لقمه الجبل بس في فرق كل واحد شلون
بيوصل الاول بيوصل الزحف والثاني بيوصل
طيران وبس توصل لا تفكر حالك ملكت الارض
وانت انجح انسان على شخص انجح شخص بهالارض
لا لا هدي مروق ما في شيء اصعب من النجاح
الا الحفاظ عليه وشكرا
[تصفيق]